Because TLB's kind of like a cache.
Let's talk about how it is organized
in terms of cache properties.
First, easy direct map of fully
associative or somewhere in between.
Well, it is small, so
it is already very fast.
So it tends to be fully or
highly associative.
Usually we don't have direct map TLBs
because that would sacrifice the hit
rate for speed, but because it's so
small, it's already very fast so
we don't really need that.
How about the TLB size?
We want it to hit at least
as often as our cache, so
we want it to cover more
memory than the cache.
So we usually want our TLB to be
somewhere about 64 to 512 entries.
What if we need more TLB entries in
order to get the hit rate that we want?
Well, you don't want it to be too large
because then it's going to become slow.
In that case,
you want to have a two-level TLB.
The first level, or level one TLB,
will be the small and
fast one that hits in a single cycle.
But if you have a miss there,
we have a larger level two TLB.
It has a hit time that
is several cycles, so
it's significantly slower than L1.
But still way faster than going through
memory and doing the translation.
And it is large.
It can be several thousand entries
because with several thousand entries we
can still support relatively good hit
times, but not a single cycle time.